c'est le début d'une invasion russe de
l'Ukraine
ils ont bombardé la centrale nucléaire
de zapporizia
va-t-on en arriver là est-ce du bluff
destiné à nous faire peur
on l'a vu l'armée russe rencontre des
difficultés dans sa guerre en Ukraine
est-ce que c'est difficulté atteignent
ces capacités nucléaires c'est ce que
nous allons voir dans ce nouvel épisode
de facture
pour pouvoir répondre à cette question
il faut prendre en compte l'héritage
soviétique on va le voir l'histoire de
l'atome et de l'URSS sont un team non
liés c'est en 1949 sous Staline que le
pays test sa première bombe nucléaire la
RDS 1 d'une puissance équivalente à
celle que les Américains ont largué sur
Nagasaki 4 ans plus tôt à sa mort en
1953 elle en possède 120 lors de la
crise des missiles de Cuba en 1962 elle
en possède 3322 en 1986 au moment de
l'accident de Tchernobyl elle en possède
45 000 à l'époque c'est presque deux
fois plus que les États-Unis lorsque
Vladimir Poutine arrive au pouvoir en
2000 la Fédération de Russie en possède
toujours 21000 aujourd'hui leur nombre
estimé à plus de 100400
par rapport au temps du RSS évidemment
il y a l'aspect quantitatif la Russie
dispose de beaucoup moins d'ogives
nucléaires que autant de la guerre
froide pendant la guerre froide les
Russes appréciaient les armes nucléaires
en faisait usage dans le discours du
point de vue à la fois politique et
militaire et soviétiques à l'époque
prométait d'ailleurs de ne jamais
utiliser
l'arme nucléaire en premier dans un dans
un conflit alors la Russie a finalement
abandonné cette politique de notre
utilisation en premier qui est une
politique de grande puissance on va dire
dominante or la Russie ne l'est plus on
voit donc que les Soviétiques ont joué
la surenchère pendant la guerre froide
mais toutes les bombes nucléaires ne se
valent pas bien qu'il existe des bombes
nucléaires dites stratégiques comme la
Tsar Bomba la plus puissante jamais
créée les Russes possèdent dans leur
arsenal des bombes à la capacité de
destruction plus réduite dites tactique
leur utilité elle pourrait être utilisée
sur le champ de bataille sans crainte
d'une réponse apocalyptique de la part
de l'ennemi du fait de leur limité le
principe des armes nucléaires tactiques
c'est la gradation théorique du
potentiel de destruction atomique et on
espère qu'on pourra en tirer des
avantages sur le plan politique et sur
le plan militaire on assiste à un retour
de ce qu'on appelle les théories de la
victoire nucléaire c'est pour ça qu'on
parle du tactique aujourd'hui on
considère qu'il y a des états pirates
qui parient de plus en plus sur
l'incapacité
de certaines puissances à utiliser
éventuellement l'arme nucléaire en gros
ça se passe très loin il y a une
agression ça ne vaut pas la chandelle
nucléaire n'utilisera pas le nucléaire
donc ces états pirates peuvent en
profiter on considère certains experts
stratégistes états considèrent depuis
quelques années que
crédibiliser l'usage éventuel des armes
nucléaires tactiques de plus faible
puissance pourrait restaurer la
dissuasion le commandement russe
pourrait donc choisir d'utiliser ces
bandes tactiques limitées contre un
ennemi qui serait assez forte mais ce
regard intérêt pour ce type de bombe
rentre en réalité dans un cadre plus
large celui de la maintenance de la
puissance nucléaire du pays face aux
États-Unis alors que son budget est
évidemment pas le même que celui de
l'URSS en fait le budget de défense
russe il est relativement limité il est
aujourd'hui environ 70 milliards il
correspond environ 70 milliards de
dollars annuels les États-Unis c'est
plus de 770 milliards de dollars annuels
on a une Russie qui finalement est une
petite puissance sur le plan budgétaire
et ces dernières années les Russes ne
pouvaient pas tout se payer donc ils ont
dû choisir on voit bien en Ukraine il y
a une sous-performance réelle
en revanche les armes nucléaires les
armes du haut du spectre les armes
nouvelles ont été des priorités ici on a
on a un danger de voir le nucléaire
comme finalement une une solution de de
surcompensation de la faiblesse
conventionnelle des Russes surtout que
ce conflit se
déroule aux abords de leur sanctuaire
national pour surcompenser les
faiblesses de son armée régulière la
Russie a donc choisi de mettre tous ses
œufs dans le même panier nucléaire alors
pour quels résultats
[Musique]
c'est en 2018 que la réponse a été
apportée par Vladimir Poutine lui-même
cette année-là le maître du Kremlin
dévoile avec fierté les nouvelles armes
invincibles dans la Russie est en train
de se doter mais s'il personique capable
de manœuvrer pour éviter les
contre-mesures drone sous-marin capable
de rester indétectable même à quelques
kilomètres des côtes ennemis ou encore
le missile sarmat dit Satan 2 à la
portée illimitée
en plus de la preuve que les Russes sont
capables d'innover dans ce domaine un
autre objectif est atteint montrer à
Washington qu'elle n'a plus l'avance
qu'elle se présumait en matière de
technologie en bref les Américains se
retrouvent coiffés au poteau pour
plusieurs années elle hérite d'une
puissance de frappe aujourd'hui encore
inégalée elle change sa doctrine pour
combler ses lacunes elle déploie des
technologies de pointe la Russie semble
donc loin d'être considéré comme une
puissance nucléaire de second rang en
somme elle continue d'être un challenger
de poids face à la puissance américaine
la Russie a conservé sa puissance
nucléaire la Russie reste une puissance
nucléaire crédible et je crois que c'est
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui les
responsables occidentaux sont
relativement prudents
[Musique]